Fox News contributors Lisa Booth Charlie
hurt Lisa start with you really now we
want to ban ceiling fans let's work with
a ceiling fan I want my ceiling fan I
like a ceiling fan I like it on uh hot
summer night get a nice breeze in my
face
like a ceiling fan Sean but look
go Biden's a dictator all right let's
just be honest we saw how he handled
covid he tried to get Force Americans to
get a vaccine that they didn't need now
he's trying to dictate controller lives
he's he's trying to arrest Donald Trump
his political opponent which is what
happens in authoritarians he's got his
missions I mean this
what but this is a guy who stood up on
stage before the midterm elections and
labeled 75 million Americans as enemies
of the state with the military flank
behind him so this guy is a bad dude he
tried telling us Corn Pop was a bad dude
Joe Biden is a bad dude and I think
that's what Americans are waking up to
right they were sold this lie that Joe
Biden is this man of integrity he's
going to unite the country he's going to
unify us he's going to bring stability
and none of that is true right we're
dealing with the country of chaos
economically over in Ukraine we're
dealing with a guy who has done nothing
to unify this nation and in fact is
trying to tear people apart so I think
Americans are waking up and realizing
that they were sold a lemon they were
sold a lie about this guy who's actually
a really bad dude when you have Chuck
Todd and and fake Jake Tapper and
liberal Joe uh Charlie uh now finally
three years later finally they've caught
up to us you know they they're used to
peddling their wise conspiracy theories
and hating Trump every second every
minute every hour of every day every
week every month every year okay now
even they are admitting oh yeah he's not
doing too good is he
um is he going to be able to survive
this seems degenerative it doesn't seem
like it's getting better with all the
vacation time he had to come back and
Mumble his way through everything how
bad was it in Maui every democrat's got
to be thinking he can't be the guy
yeah it does seem to be getting a whole
lot worse uh recently but you know it's
amazing uh listening to people like Jake
Tapper talk about how uh there's
suddenly there's an age problem my
goodness this anybody who's been in
Washington the past 50 years knows has
known Joe Biden and obviously the age
Factor makes it infinitely worse but we
saw that even in 2020 when he refused
even campaign for office and to listen
to people in the media now claim like oh
this just came up that's that's so
disingenuous the problem for Joe Biden
is he's been he's been in Washington for
50 years 50 years he's always been a
liar everybody's known he's a liar he's
gotten run out of at least two
presidential campaigns because he was
lying the problem now is he's he's
become so senile we don't know whether
it's lies he's telling or it's just his
senility setting in and he's making up
these crazy stories about Strom Thurman
the one good thing about the guy is he's
unified the country in one way
77 of Americans don't want to see him
run again they want him to retire now
and that's a pretty good figure if you
ask me in in politics today if you can
get 77 of Americans to agree on anything
exit question I'll start with you Lisa
Booth between his cognitive decline and
the bribery and money laundering
allegation scandals and now the this is
now making it into the the main artery
of the political bloodstream in this
country it every American will know this
by November of 2024 and understand the
tens of millions of dollars this family
got paid and grandchildren got paid for
no experience and his influence on this
do you think they make the move the
Democratic party to take him off the
ticket I believe yes what do you say
Lisa
I don't know yet I'm not convinced and
can I just say my favorite Joe Biden lie
is when he said that he went to go visit
Nelson Mandela and he was arrested in
the 1970s in South Africa and it turned
out he was just he was just separated
from his colleagues at the airport that
was literally it and to Charlie's point
at his option C he's old and he's a liar
it's both it's all of the above so will
he be the candidate you you can't say
Charlie
against me
because every time you ask this question
I give you a different answer but
honestly the problem now with them is
their alternative is they don't have an
alternative but if they had any
alternatives I think they do absolutely
drop him because it's hopeless watch out
for Gavin Newsom there's my prediction
all right thank you both hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else